on September 15 1940 the lufafa began a
ferocious campaign targeting London a
sudden change in tactics focusing the
full might of their Air Force on the
most heavily populated city in Great
Britain over the course of this brutal
day over 1 100 German aircraft entered
British airspace an astonishing Invasion
to attack a non-strategic civilian
Target however this was all part of the
lufafa's plan to gain air superiority in
British Skies baiting British fighter
planes into the sky to face off against
their German counterparts a showdown to
eliminate the Royal Air Force as a
threat to pave the way for a German
amphibious invasion of Britain on this
first day of the infamous Blitz over 1
000 aircraft on both sides Tangled in
the skies above London the Loof offer
believed the RAF were on their last legs
but that couldn't have been further from
the truth
the Spitfires and hurricanes being
manufactured in astonishing numbers
outpacing the attrition of the battle
Rose to meet the challenge
the pilots of the Loof offer flying the
bf-109 were astonished at the resistance
they met however another number from
this period stands out to me over the
course of this month the sixth
anti-aircraft division covering the
Thames estri the main approach to London
from Europe expended over a quarter of a
million anti-aircraft rounds in its
effort to protect the citizens of London
a bill will drink 1 800 rounds were
needed to take down a single aircraft on
this day according to official records
these numbers are largely accepted by
experts as false with actual rounds
needed much higher
many downed German aircraft claimed by
anti-aircraft Crews were in fact shot
down by fighters in the sky the cause of
these false reports and anti-aircraft
Technologies in Effectiveness were the
same so why was anti-aircraft technology
during the Battle of Britain so
ineffective that damaging invading
planes and how did an ingenious top
secret technology introduced in the
middle of the war changed the face of
the battlefield forever
at the outbreak of the war anti-aircraft
technology was for the most part a
deterrent a weapon that became vastly
more effective at lower altitudes and in
turn forced enemy aircraft high above
the clouds where they themselves
struggled to hit the Merc the task of
accurately targeting a high-flying
aircraft from the ground was an even
more immense challenge in the best case
scenario anti-aircraft Crews had a
direct line of sight with their target
allowing them to estimate both altitude
bearing and speed this information was
used to aim their barrels to a location
in front of the formation's current
location an educated guess of where they
would be when the shells arrived
to make this task even harder Allied
fuses had to be timed on the ground
turning a dial on a mechanically timed
fuse
calculating the time it would take for
the round to reach the Target in the
heat of battle was difficult these
calculations needed to be incredibly
accurate allowing the anti-aircraft
rounds to explode in close proximity to
their targets this variable was also
subject to change as Pilots were
instructed to change their altitude and
bearing randomly to make it impossible
to predict flight time and future
location
this was a game of chance and as such
relied on an incredible volume of fire
to stand a chance of damaging their
target
this problem needed to be solved and was
high on the mind of the British as they
held through the brutal storm of this
bombing campaign
for anti-aircraft rounds to become
vastly more effective they needed a way
to detect their target
in the era of fragile vacuum tubes
building an electronic device capable of
surviving the immense 20 000 G
acceleration launch out of a gun barrel
was a task that was deemed impossible
work began on radar triggered fuses in
both Britain and Germany before the war
broke out and both abandoned the idea
completely for gun launched projectiles
seeing no way to overcome the technical
challenge of ruggedizing the electronics
while miniaturizing them to fit into a
small artillery shell fuse however the
Americans persevered and came up with
this the VT fuse with its ominous red
vial of liquid at its core serving a
vital purpose
challenge of finding a suitable power
source for this radar transmitter was
another challenge facing the engineers
early versions of the proximity fuse
utilized existing dry cell battery
technology but these came with two huge
issues their charge would fade in just
two to three months making long-term
storage of these fuses impossible and
secondly the risk of having power
accidentally connect to the transmitter
and receiver was far too high a single
failure Point could explode an entire
ammunition stockpile
for a reminder of what that looks like
this is not a nuclear bomb this is the
SS John Burke a United States ammunition
transport ship that was struck by a
Japanese Kamikaze bomber while
transporting ammunition to the
Philippines in 1944. the war in the
Pacific was the driving force for the
invention of the proximity fuse the US
were losing an astonishing number of
ships to Japanese aerial attacks and
desperately needed a better way to
defend their ships with anti-aircraft
fire the solution the U.S national
defense research committee came up with
to solve this issue of safely powering
this device was as bizarre and unique as
it was ingenious
the engineer switched to a wet cell
design this red vial contains the
electrolyte of the battery this allowed
for an ingenious workaround for both
problems the liquid electrolyte was
stored inside the battery separated from
the solid plates of the battery inside
this vial underneath this glass ampule
lay a breaker that contained a clever
mechanism two levers were pushed towards
the center of the mechanism by a spring
when the round began to spin at 50 000
revolutions per minute as a result of
the rifling in the gun barrel these
levers would be forced out which
released a trigger allowing a small
explosive primer to force a spiked
plunger to break free and strike the
glass ampule breaking it and releasing
the electrolyte into the battery the
plates of the battery were composed of
thin zinc plates coated in Carbon on one
side each layer separated by a plastic
insulating ring and each disc had holes
punched into it to allow the electrolyte
to flow and fill each layer this glass
could of course break with rough
handling but the electrolyte would not
fill the space between the battery
plates without the centrifugal force of
the round forcing the liquid outwards
into the surrounding plates other safety
measures were Incorporated to make
absolutely sure that the chances of an
accidental detonation could only happen
when the round was in the air and spun
at tremendous speeds once energized this
battery would provide power to the
oscillator which generated a continuous
sine wave radio current to the
transmitter for space efficiency's sake
the antenna operated as both a
transmitter and receiver with the
currents traveling through the same
antenna the fuse needed a way to
differentiate between the signal sent
and the signal received for this the
engineers could turn to the Doppler
effect as the Target and fuse are
traveling towards each other we can
easily calculate the apparent frequency
shift due to their relative velocity
then with some basic math we can come up
with this equation subtracting the
reflected frequency from the actual
frequency this was called the beast note
this beat note is what the fuse used to
detonate the round the amplitude of this
beat signal would also grow as the round
approaches the target providing a signal
that looks something like this with
amplification
the fuse was tuned to explode at the
optimum distance and angle away from the
Target by tailoring the radar
sensitivity to match the fragmentation
pattern of the shells when the round
approached the target the returning
radar waves would generate the necessary
threshold voltage to trigger the
thyrotron a type of high-speed
electrical switch
it looks a lot like a vacuum tube but it
was filled with a low pressure gas like
hydrogen when a voltage of sufficient
magnitude was passed from the amplifier
to the cathode grid of the tyrotron it
would ionize the gas inside and allow
current to flow to the anode through its
glowing cloud of ionized atoms
completing a circuit to a capacitor that
in turn would detonate the high
explosive charge in the round creating a
cloud of shrapnel at the optimum
distance away from the targets this
whole assembly consisting of the vividly
red electrolyte capsule the zinc carbon
battery plates oscillator antenna
amplifier and thyotron was then inserted
into the fuse body and the cavities of
the fuse were filled with a micro
crystalline wax for moisture protection
and critically mechanically support the
electronics to keep everything in place
during launch packaging this all in a
fuse this small in the 1940s was no easy
Feast the tubes manufactured for the
proximity fuse were drastically smaller
than existing conventional tubes this of
course helped immensely with resisting
the force of launch with 20 000 G's of
acceleration every extra gram of weight
saving makes the difference with this
multiplication of mass a single gram
would weigh 20 kilograms
the engineering challenge of ensuring
every gram of mass inside this fuse was
supported by a structure capable of
bearing 20 kilograms was immense a
challenge that deterred both the British
and Germans and its success drastically
changed the face of the battlefield
the impact this fuse had on the war
cannot be overstated the atomic bomb was
the punctuation mark of this worldwide
war but the statistics backed the VT
fuse as the most impactful invention of
the war an invention that changed The
Narrative of the war completely a
counter to the newly invented airplane
causing Havoc across every theater of
the war
such importance was put on this
invention that it was classified as top
secret and only approved for use in the
Pacific where any unexploded rounds
would be lost to Sea much of the
manufacturing was performed in smaller
sub-assemblies to minimize any
knowledgeable manufacturer from deducing
the purpose of the device and for good
reason during the London Blitz it's
estimated that 1 800 rounds were needed
to take down a single aircraft but with
the introduction of the VT fuse this
number lowered to an average of 85 to
100 rounds a 10 to 20 times increase in
lethality a jump in lethality that Grace
is akin to the introduction of the
machine gun this was beyond a doubt a
game-changing invention at the peak of
their production over a quarter of a
million of these fuses were being
manufactured a week the VT fuse was
first fired on January 4th 1943 on board
the cruiser Helena defending itself from
an aerial assault and successfully
shooting the aircraft down this device
had a devastating effect on the aerial
battles of the Pacific Japan soon began
to run low on trained pilots and a year
later began the Kamikaze campaign
sending waves of untrained Pilots
towards American ships in the hopes just
one could get through in May 1945 two
destroyers off Okinawa found themselves
the targets of 150 Kamikaze aircraft
every single one of them was shot down a
feat that could not have been achieved
without the radio proximity fuse
allowing The Guns of these boats to fire
relentlessly with accurate fire with
with no pauses to fiddle with the
mechanically timed fuses had the VT fuse
been available during the Battle of
Britain the battle would have been even
shorter left with the anti-aircraft guns
of London suddenly becoming an order of
magnitude more effective the Swarms of
the Lou Fafa bombers would have stood
little chance of returning home it was
finally approved for use over land for
the first time in conjunction with the
Allied invasion of Normandy a week
before Germany began bombarding Britain
with the V1 buzzbomb at its peak 100 v1s
were launched towards Britain and with
the help of the VT fuse 80 percent of
these automated missiles were shot down
the VT fuse also played a pivotal role
in the Battle of the Bulge allowing
artillery fire to explode at the perfect
distance of her head showering the
canopy of the Ardene's forest with
deadly shrapnel repelling Germany's
final large-scale counter-offensive of
the war
even at this stage of the war with
Germany on the retreat the VT fuse was a
closely guarded secret each and every
fuse needed to be tracked and accounted
for with one story of artillery officers
spending hours searching through snow to
locate lost fuses during the Battle of
the Bulge only for them to be returned
to them by locals
World War II was defined by
technological progress when the entire
world was at War a nation's very
survival was at stake Innovation was
placed at the very Pinnacle of national
interests and this is the reason I find
the war so fascinating I have created
two series the logistics of D-Day and
Battle of Britain detailing the
innovations that helped win these
critical battles I put little focus on
the military tactics or individual
soldiers on the ground this is the view
of these battles from the perspective of
an engineering nerd the logistics of
transporting tanks across the English
Channel How The Joint game-like board at
the center of RAF command worked during
the Battle of Britain and the final
episode of the Battle of Britain shares
the astonishing manufacturing
innovations that allowed Britain to out
manufacture Germany in fighter planes
and prevent aircraft attrition from
affecting their ranks if you are an
engineering nerd like me these are the
series for you if you want to watch
these series the only place you can find
them is nebula the streaming platform I
created with some of my closest YouTube
friends it's absolutely packed with
fantastic engineering content creators
mustard has this incredible original
documentary about the B2 bomber City
beautiful has this fantastic original
series talking about the history of the
world's best cities and Neo made this
20-minute documentary about the flight
investigation of mh-17 these are just
some of the shows only available on
nebula and you can get access for just
five dollars a month but if you sign up
with my link in the description you can
get access for half that price at 250 a
month you get all of that original
content and all of our videos ad free
and early on nebula 2. so you can see
them before anyone else on YouTube we
created nebula to allow us to speak
freely without worry of YouTube's
Community guidelines affecting our
business in this video I did my best to
tiptoe around certain words and image
imagery that could trigger
demonetization but that's not something
I have to worry about In My World War II
series on nebula nebula is the world's
largest creator-owned streaming service
and it's only growing and allowing us to
fund incredible Creator projects that
would just not be possible without
direct funding from our viewers so why
not sign up for just 250 a month by
clicking the link on screen right now to
get access to incredible exclusive
content that you can have a direct hand
in funding